it's here the neural networks
from scratch in python from myself and
daniel kukiela it is over 650 pages of
pure python goodness where we
essentially are creating our very own
deep learning framework
in python really with the purpose of
learning truly
how neural networks actually work the
idea here is not
so you can make your own deep learning
framework you know in python and then
use that going forward
instead it is just simply to get an
understanding
of how deep learning works so that when
you use a framework
you actually know what are these these
parameters that i'm changing here what
do they actually mean
and when things don't work what might
you consider changing
to get things to actually begin to work
so the book comes in two physical forms
you've got the hard cover version here
that you see
we also have a soft cover version if
that is what you are
after and then finally we have the ebook
version if you get any version
any physical version of the book you
also get the ebook version but you can
also buy the ebook
all by itself the ebook also comes with
the ability for you
to ask questions or make comments
in line with the text of the book
so if you're having problems anywhere
along the way you can
you can do that and i think that's
probably the best way to get help with
with the content of the book
the hardcover and softcover version of
the book
both come in full color which is very
useful both for the many charts and
diagrams that we have
in the book also all charts and diagrams
or at least most of them
wind up having also qr codes which you
can scan with your camera on your phone
most relatively recent phones well the
camera app will just automatically
recognize that and allow you to go there
otherwise you can also download apps
from the app store which will
use your camera to read qr codes but
these will link to actual videos
of animations and so on so if you're
having a hard time understanding or you
just want to even a more full
understanding of what we're trying to
show
we do have those all through the book
also you could just go directly to those
urls
now beyond having color for the diagrams
and charts we also have color because
this is a
programming book and to make it easier
to read the actual
syntax of the python language that is
why we have syntax highlighting in
basically every editor that you might
use
so the same thing is true here we have
sent full syntax color highlighting for
all of the python code
which for one just reading it and
understanding it that makes it a whole
lot easier than if it
had been black and white and then also
it gives us the ability so for example
as we make reference to various python
objects so for example as you're reading
this text you get to is instance what
are we talking about you can well
you can find it so much quicker because
of the syntax highlighting
so anytime we're referencing python
object uh we try
to use the uh the actual the actual
syntax highlighting that would be
in reference to that object just so it's
even that much easier to go back to the
code and find it so now coming to the
table of contents for the actual book
and what it covers
we obviously have a brief introduction
to neural networks what are we actually
trying to do here and very quickly we're
getting into coding our very first
neurons we begin to code a layer of
neurons and have multiple layers
of neurons then we get into activation
functions not only how do we code them
but
what are activation functions why do we
actually use them
and going over this can both
conceptually and via code to show
how that actually works calculating
network error with loss
again showing all of the mathematics and
then the python implementation
of that math then we get into
optimization which really is the
challenge the hard part of neural
networks um so
first we just kind of introduce the
concept of of optimization
and really why is this so hard and
essentially it's we're we're attempting
to
to optimize um a very large function
with millions of parameters
so um that's actually that turns out to
be quite the hard problem
uh so then we get into how this is
actually done
with derivatives more specifically
partial derivatives with these huge
functions
then how do we back propagate those
things and at least initially the
concept of back propagation
at its most basic form is going to be
using the stochastic gradient descent
optimizer
but there are other optimizers including
variations to vanilla
stochastic gradient descent so
specifically with something like
momentum but then we also get into
adegrad
rms prop and of course the atom
optimizer
after we get through the optimizers we
talk about testing out of sample data
validation data training data
beyond that we get into regularization
so if the network is having a hard time
learning a lot of times regularization
techniques can
significantly help with generalization
we also up kind of up to this point
we're doing classification
specifically with multi more than two
classes but we also cover binary
logistic regression
regression um and then also
basically up to this point we've we've
it's not
really a framework until we get to the
model object and this is kind of the
point where we kind of convert
everything to be very very
object-oriented programming
and pretty much at this point i would
say we have
a deep learning framework we cover a
realistic data set because up to this
point we use a kind of a generated
data set just to make learning easier
testing quicker and so on realistic data
sets are usually quite large we use
neural networks
with very vast data sets rather than
small data sets we would use different
forms of machine learning if the data
set
in most cases if the data set isn't very
big but at some point we actually want
to learn okay we've got a realistic data
set how do we break this data down
to become input into a neural network
then we go through model evaluation as
well as saving and loading models so if
you have a model that you really like
you want to save it or during training
if any point you need to pause and come
back later that is how you can do it or
if you want to save checkpoints along
the way
you need to be able to save and then if
you want to use your model you need to
be able to load the model
then we cover prediction and inference
and then of course
at some point the book must end so the
book ends at a little over 660
pages so there you have it the neural
networks from scratch book
now available thank you to all of our
pre-orders and especially the
kickstarter backers
who backed the book really before there
was almost any content available for you
guys even to read
so i really appreciate that i appreciate
everybody who has taken part in reading
the draft document
asking all your questions you might not
think that asking a question is actually
helpful to us but it really really was
i said it before i'll say it again i
think this book is already in like a v2
situation just simply because of
how many people have been through this
book how many questions have been asked
all the edits and changes that have been
made we have changed so much of the
content in this book
to in an effort to make it more clear
more understandable based on
even just the questions people asked
also all the people who
issued edits either grammar mistakes or
actual just
things got flipped or just outright
mistakes that were made
in this much content it's very hard for
you know two authors to
to catch every single mistake so thank
you to everyone who has contributed
both in editing as well as just asking
questions
also again thank you to thomas halverson
and spencer churchill who heavily edited
the actual text and grammar and english
of the book
so anyway that's it the book is now
available you can get it at nnfs.io
again
shipping can take anywhere from one to
three weeks if not possibly even more
we don't really have too many data
points at this point so
let us know how long did it take for you
to get your book and where you live also
when you do get your book please share
images
of your book with us on twitter or via
email
or or whatever we want to see your books
one for quality control purposes but
also two
it just put a big smile on both myself
and daniel's face to
see these books so please do share it
with us
and let us know what you think anyway
that's all for now
thank you again thank you again everyone
for your support in this project
and i will see you guys in the neural
networks from scratch videos which we're
going to be starting up
very soon for short in the month of
november we should start
seeing some releases of new videos so
stay tuned for those
until next time
you